ja bloß weil ein gesetz ende des corona
nicht vorbei aber das ist ja unser
grundproblem politische entscheidungen
sind das eine aber es war haben wir in
den letzten jahren gemerkt kam warum es
hängt von der infektionsgeschehen ab von
der vorsicht der menschen ich glaube
aber dass die menschen in deutschland
schon jetzt sehr bewusst agieren und das
impfen hilft uns auch sehr und durch
zwei mal hat man einfach mehr mehr
freiheiten ist sollten diese scheinen
dass die abstände zwischen erst und
zweitens beispielsweise bei aastra
zenica
das hat man jetzt freigegeben sie
erinnern sich vielleicht werden bayern
gehen wird zumal kritisiert gehen immer
einen schritt schneller voran es bei den
hausärzten impfen gemacht wir haben das
gemacht jetzt beispielsweise bei der
frage welche rechte kämpfen haben das
wird auch immer alle anderen vollziehen
ist dann gott sei dank
danach ist dann immer gleich alles gut
und das sind glaube ich dass wir da
schon sehr gut vorankommen und wenn wir
jetzt noch gelänge beispielsweise bei
astrazeneca den abstand zwischen acht
und zwei impfungen noch ein bisschen zu
verkürzen erhöht sich auch die
wirksamkeit des impfstoffs maßnahmen
eben noch den ganzen sommer gehen sie
davon aus also die pandemie die pandemie
bekämpfung auf der gesetzlichen
grundlage einer notbremse geht bis zum
30.06
und dann wird man sehen wie die gesamt
war ist